it's the bunking time the bunk and Bros
are back as debunking experts we've
looked to the skies above we've looked
at Cryptids on the ground but we haven't
looked in the deep forest
where another mysterious paranormal
creature lives
going by the name a Bigfoot breaking
news out of Texas big
we've all had experiences that have
changed our lives in the swabs of
Northwest Mississippi come out with me
in the field and I will show you a
sasquatch today we are going to apply
our trained visual effects eye on
Bigfoot footage
there's some good tasty stuff out there
I gotta give a shout out to Ernesto oh
my Ernesto put together a compilation of
a bunch of Bigfoot clips that he thinks
are the most authentic and realistic
ones and sent it our way so we're going
to take a look at this first off before
we get into it
do you guys think Bigfoot is real I want
to believe look I'm open-minded but I'm
skeptical and scrutinizing are we just
gonna see a bunch of shots of a dude in
a costume we might but you know what
let's take a look so this we're starting
with the 1967 Patterson gimlet footage
this is probably the most recognizable
Bigfoot footage out there
wow this is really nice in here whoa
this is really nicely enhanced wait what
the heck they're doing our job for us
this is great yeah if this doesn't
convince you that Bigfoot is real then
what would because as you can I look at
this and it kind of looks like Bigfoot
if you like the scale it looks like a
regular sized human being you know six
feet tall or so proportioned the same as
a human being if you like cut off the
butt and like skinny it up a little bit
it's like exactly human being
proportions the gate is human-like
there's really nothing that's not
anatomically different than a human
outside of just outward appearance of it
being a lot of hair well he's a real
thick boy too
yeah very he's got a thickness to him oh
wait you can see he's wearing shoes look
at the feet yeah those look like Souls
they look like boots or something like
that I think that's the thing that's
giving it away right now he's nude right
this is a nude Bigfoot so theoretically
we'd be seeing some sort of feat here
but it appears more like there's boots
on it yeah there's like a white stripe
and dark stripe at the bottom of his
foot there it feels very art directed by
somebody with a gorilla costume you know
dude is it straight up just like a
costume from Planet of the Apes that
they got on 1960s eBay and have made a
super great film with it Bob claims it
back in 67 he was the guy who Strode
across Bluff Creek in Patterson's
Bigfoot suit this is the guy look at
that walk that's him
oh he's got that yeah
that thick boy he does have the walk I'm
not gonna lie and and the shoulders yeah
here's what convinced me Bigfoot being
real if hard to see it something that's
clearly physically not human as in too
tall bone structure is too different you
know something like outside of like just
being furry you squint your eyes the
silhouette the straw the skeleton that's
driving this thing like that needs to be
different than a human being when you
have like dogs like people wearing dog
costumes like the Velociraptors you know
from like Jurassic Park like those
costumes they're trying to hide a
human's anatomy in the anatomy of
something else but once again if like
it's if you look closely you can trace
where a human could be in that you know
yeah it'd be cool to like see something
where if you trace it there's nowhere a
human could be in dude reverse sneeze
can't fit yeah reverse knees or or just
demonstrating like Superior strength
like if you picked up that log there and
threw it I'd be like that costume can't
do that or if he moved in just like a
non-casual walk something that's not
human right if everything is human
outside of just it being potentially
furry it's like well you can chalk it up
to bigger costume and that's the simpler
of explanations therefore razor
therefore fake
all right I'm I mean but this has been
settled for decades right come on 2013
it was allegedly shot in the swabs of
Northwest Mississippi
oh oh this guy is awfully close to a
terrifyingly large creature this dude is
like maybe 50 feet away like you'd be so
loud getting to that point we are
getting a decent look at it from this
angle row you know if bigfoots have been
around this long and you can get this
close to them why hasn't anyone shot one
[Laughter]
also this costume appears to be far
worse than the one in the original yes
laughing that that natural like hairy
Sheen you just be real if you're gonna
find a Bigfoot you're probably going to
find it in like Africa like Africa like
the Middle East like that area isn't the
idea that like Bigfoot is like something
other than a homo sapien that means that
it had to have originated at least back
then right and branched off and somehow
managed to survive hundreds of thousands
of years there's absolutely zero
evidence to point to it not being a
person in a costume therefore I'm
inclined to believe the likely
explanation of it being a person in a
costume and not the one in bajillion
chance that it's a new species of ape
that's in Mississippi yeah
another swamp here we go down into Bayou
he's drinking to buy you so he's doing
one of these yeah I can barely tell
could be a Bigfoot but when you see
Anatomy or a gate or something that's
not human here it's almost like
mimicking the Bigfoot walk from the
first one he's going like this as he
walks through it there's like a speed to
how humans will move right like the way
I can move my arm fast and like the way
it shakes my body like there's a certain
amount of mass that like humans kind of
have and how fast we can move that mass
even just watching somebody move in
costume you can kind of see that so like
let's just take a look at a gorilla
walking here like the speed is different
right like look at the anatomy the way
the knees are bending the way the ankles
are more like the butt is the body the
arms like you wouldn't be able to fit a
human being into that costume it feels a
little bit different than a person like
it moves a little bit different
accelerates a little bit different like
you can tell it weighs a different
amount and its muscles already have a
different strength notice like because
of their Mass there is just a different
way that they move and operate you know
Bigfoot isn't a gorilla so it's not we
shouldn't expect it to walk like a
gorilla but from like the closest living
thing that we can you know give
reference to there's a couple of things
you can start to notice that could prove
differences the proportions are entirely
different between a gorilla and a person
the legs are significantly shorter and
the arms are significant longer and you
can like adjust the CG bones of a rigged
character it's kind of like sort of
create the elongated arms but like
you're talking about then all of the
actual emotions are going to be
different because it's like propagating
outwards to really high speeds along the
fingertips if you extend the arms and
it's like these guys aren't doing that
because they actually have that mass out
there that's resisting it it's called
inertia when we build costumes and props
for movies a lot of times We'll add
weight to them like prop guns like
sci-fi guns so use like a Nerf gun and
you'll paint it or whatever but they
need to add weight to it so that it
looks heavy and same thing like with the
costume if you're trying to build a
gorilla costume like this you almost
need to like add like weights like here
and in your hands so you have to like
balance all that and it shows up in your
gate you know somebody could do that in
a in a bigfoot costume but I haven't
really seen that in any of these videos
so far we've looked at
okay there it is some good walking
there's some good walking can you see
anything that is impossible for a human
in a costume to do did he slip it looks
like he slipped it looks like he slipped
and fell I think he did I think I think
you would see a lot of slipping and
falling when somebody's wearing fake
gorilla shoes and they're a human being
in a costume walking in the woods oh he
just threw us
through a stripped over a stick and was
like screw that stick and throws it the
speed of the arm it's a totally normal
human speed the mechanics of it totally
normal human mechanics if you're going
to do a visual effect shot or like a
special effects character you need to
add something to it to sell it right
yeah it's like Voldemort not having a
nose like you can't do that with makeup
right they're selling it they're doing a
little bit more to make it a magic trick
so if you're gonna show me a Bigfoot you
need to show me not just a person with a
costume show me something that a person
couldn't do sell it if you can sell it
then I'll get excited
well at least this one's filming from
the right distance here just as Bigfoot
likely has super human hearing abilities
you would be able to hear a giant oh my
God that's a guy
[Laughter]
the least Bigfoot looking
silhouette I think we've seen so far
when it comes to creatures that have
evolved to live in mountainous
environments like this there's like a
certain like Grace yeah that they have
dude mountain goats exactly like you see
these creatures even deer you know moose
like all these creatures just can handle
the terrain with Grace but that
literally looks like a dude who's going
all right I don't want to split down
this thing I'm going to do a little hop
over this rock here and bounding up
there one thing to point out here like
sure we're talking a lot about how we're
able to tell that it's not Bigfoot but
on the other side there's an element of
being able to recognize something that's
human that's like another quality that
is playing here I think this Bigfoot
footage really works on that sense more
than anything else it's easier to say
it's human than it is that it's fake
because where true fear comes from where
the ocean
we haven't looked at sea monsters
I want to do a sea monster debunk dude
well the problem there is I'm just gonna
believe everything I see I think that's
a really good one of all the Realms of
like Paranormal creatures the ocean kind
of has some real ones
if you want to share some actual footage
that you have yourself or some raw video
debunk Corridor digital.com we would
love some ocean monsters to look at
because you know as we just discovered
they've only just figured out how to
simulate water in Avatar too I was about
to say I'm kind of done stating whether
or not a water shot is practical or CG
that's what you think red
are you seeing these uh fake camera
zooms and fake
yeah the aesthetic of the camera going
out of focus and back into Focus also
the fake tone mapping on everything like
the unsharp nass honey I see your
Bigfoot like wait wait wait don't chase
it it's like don't worry
full Zoom
it's a dude it's a dude it's another
dude of a perfect human proportion and
why are we surprised I feel like in like
the 70 years or 60 years we've had big
feet walking around that we'd like
yeah innovated in the Bigfoot space like
you know
this is half a debunking video in half
what you can do
to make better Bigfoot footage for the
world maybe change it up maybe the hair
only comes down to here and you get
weird like fleshy Bigfoot feet you know
that'd be kind of cool or maybe you can
see their face a little bit better he
goes you know like whoa he made an
expression yeah or maybe hear a crazy
yell in the distance you can really set
the door yeah but it's like a really
eerie non-human Screech
and you hear it echo in the woods a
little bit of sound design a little tip
for you guys
wait he's got a baby he's holding a baby
Bigfoot baby Bigfoot okay still kind of
feels like monkey costumes you do not
have my permission to film my son
oh and move there that's wait I think
that's a child in a costume I think they
did try to innovate in the space I'm not
gonna lie I think we are seeing some
Innovation here someone's four or
five-year-old child is also wearing a
tiny or gorilla costume I think I think
you're right I think I think we still
saw somebody try to sell it somebody
tried to sell it
yeah wait it's it's it's it's in this
one it's like it's even less about the
visuals but it's it's about the
narrative yeah and sometimes a narrative
is even stronger than an image you're
right Child by association means there's
at least one more Bigfoot out there well
that's a cool like twist to the story I
thought there was just one Immortal
Bigfoot
it did like that first like but that
could have just been the arm just kind
of like holding it out for a moment but
it looked like the baby was like looking
up it could be a doll it does move a bit
like a doll like the way it shakes a
little bit it's like
and it's just so static for the rest of
the shot so is the the quality of the
footage aiding or hurting I mean it
helps the mythology but doesn't help
like the proof I just once again I'm
thinking about the cameraman perspective
sometimes yeah we're looking at Bigfoot
but you have to consider what's going on
here all right let's say you're walking
in the mountains and you see a grizzly
bear and it's this far away what 40 feet
50 feet what do you do like I pull out
the bear spray and pray exactly I mean
that's one of the least convincing Parts
about most of this footage is just the
Fear Factor yeah the lack of any
sensible like positioning of the camera
person like there's nothing more
dangerous than being 40 feet away from a
grizzly bear like with a cub with Oman
you're already dead already dead yeah so
I just I can't buy most of this footage
because of that like the context of the
the situation just doesn't even make
sense do you think we'll get like any
actual realistic looking Bigfoot footage
so these guys at Corridor love to try to
debunk me but today I'm flipping it
around and I'm gonna debunk them I stole
the guy who made these sweet little
Graphics here and I'm gonna sit him down
and force him to make an hour-long
tutorial showing me exactly how he built
these templates in Fusion if you want to
check that out it's out now on Corridor
digital.com you can go watch it yourself
there's a link down below and guess what
there's a free trial too because Bigfoot
doesn't use money I just use pine cones
I'll see you over there at Corridor
digital.com and together we can debunk
these so-called debunkers
yeah
foreign
goodbye for this one it's zoomed in it's
crisp and clear I mean I'm definitely
getting a sense that this is a big thing
wait is this an actual like Yeti this
one's cool I like this one it feels like
it moves a little bit differently see
how it feels like it's a little bit
heavier like the way it sways it doesn't
move like a person it's just the the it
feels like there's more mass also the
scale of the matting on the fur there
you can clearly see and then there's
like patterning to the fur like you kind
of see as like the textures yeah I don't
know about that there's so little to go
off of like this is just like the back
of an animal or a Bigfoot hey that that
looks freaking yeah it looks familiar
doesn't it I'm gonna Adventure that this
is actually just a wild animal like a
bear but it's really cool that's like a
freaking Silverback bear
just recording my yard
hey Bob what are you doing today I'm
just gonna film the old yard kick back
it's like okay oh he's gonna climb a
fence just wait now oh he's coming back
does he climb the fence down I'm
sneaking I'm sneaking
[Laughter]
this is so clearly a dude who's just
like I want to make a squeaky shot oh my
God
now I find myself really wanting to see
someone get really creative with how to
actually get a Bigfoot shot the really
the big thing that works against a lot
of this is that people are using
filmmaking tropes in shooting this it's
always like it's a shaky camera it's the
running while like filming the ground
zooming in slightly off center yeah and
not actually framing up the object yeah
but you think putting the work into how
it's filmed is going to somehow make it
more realistic like putting a leaf in
front of it is not necessarily going to
make it feel more real like if I was
going to try to make a Bigfoot video I
tried to first off make it clear enough
that you can see it so I'm not like
doesn't feel like I'm hiding something
not so clear that you can completely
analyze it but clearly enough where it's
like it's worth looking at right then I
would either put like stilts on or put
something like in my hands with like
mechanical fingers or like have the head
raised up higher and I'm like you know
puppet or something like that I would do
something to make it anatomically not a
human well it's also kind of funny
because that original Bigfoot footage is
still like the best shot yeah like
compared to everything else we've seen
so far that original film footage is the
far more convincing than any of this the
the costume and the walk and the setting
yeah it's in sunlight it's just it like
it's a good costume for sure that's the
first part it doesn't look like it's
made out of like synthetic like plastic
hair looks like it's made out of real
fur it's got the right Sheen to it like
so there's just a lot of things going
for it not to mention the body is a
little bit weirder and bigger and more
gorilla-like and whereas all these other
ones are just I like kind of lower
effort versions of it like you can
actually see the detail in that 1967
shot we can't see any detail on any of
these other shots yeah
you know I'm kind of disappointed none
of them sold the effect at all download
this video squash your hopes and dreams
the world is still a magical place
because we don't know what's in the
ocean
[Laughter]
goodbye everyone
continue believing